I don't like foods I love it if I don't
love it I don't swallow now whilst this
character from the 2007 film ratatouille
may be unique in his ways it is pretty
well known that we don't just eat
because of Henry's asset Conger but also
to satisfy cravings and hedonic hunger
our intense desire to eat specific feeds
our path for broad appetite if response
pattern to stimuli in our environment
that signal the availability of foods
and this is referred to ads the feed
queue reactivity studies have shown that
high calorie feeds with high sugar and
fat contents compared with low calorie
foods enhances our feed q reactivity
this may have been adaptive for when
food was sparse but it's actually
problematic for those of us now
surrounded by food queues in combination
with the constant availability of foods
living in Western societies so food
cravings combines with food availability
can result in overeating and weight gain
but what if there was a way to reduce
this feed queue reactivity or what if
there was a way where you could eat your
favorite foods without even consuming
the calories and what if you could eat
foods that you were previously allergic
to well hello and welcome to the shaky
science show where in this video I'm
going to investigate these questions and
talk about some recent technology that
we could see in the near future
involving both augmented reality and
virtual reality into a form of eating
known as virtual eating and then we'll
also look at whether you could just
suppress these food cravings just by
imagining yourself eating before we
address these two different topics we
first need to talk about the science of
gastro physics which is the scientific
discipline which is brought about by the
combination of gastronomy and
psychophysics
in order to research the multi-sensory
experience while eating or drinking so
gastro physics is a pretty big field but
it touches on how many factors influence
our perception of food and this ranges
from the smell the taste the texture the
temperature and even the sounds that are
created while
we bite into you and taste our foods in
addition the branding and the name of
the products can also affect how it
tastes
wishes almonds touch makes the public
feel more comfortable along with our
increase in the understanding of gastro
physics is our development of
technologies that are more sustainable
for our planets just to give one example
many articles talk about how edible
insects kiss play a large role in the
future of our food consumption so
adopting to more sustainable food
strategies will definitely require
changes in our food behavior and food
perception so what solutions are there
to help us adapt to these changes and
also try and prevent increased feed key
reactivity well as often seems to be the
case these days The Simpsons came up
with solution in the episode parts of
the future that came out in the year
2000 in the subsides at one point we see
Homer and Marge chomping away at some
virtual fudge yeah this tastes like crap
and say what to miss episodes 20 years
later it seems that the creators of The
Simpsons but actually onto something a
gastronomical virtual reality experience
called Project nourished is focusing on
allowing its users to experience a new
way of dining with no calorie intake
coupled with olfactory and haptic use so
the aim behind project nourished is
being able to merge the physicality of
molecular gastronomy with virtual
reality the components required for such
a device would involve aromatic
diffusers to give the smell of the feed
a virtual reality headset a bone
conduction transducer which would be a
device that could mimic the chewing
sounds that are transmitted from the
diner's mouth to the eardrums fear soft
tissues and bones the gyroscope akyuu
tensile and 3d printed tasteless foods
and so this feed would be made from
algae and yeast and so whilst this
technology is still in development it is
interesting to think about all the
different potential applications of this
technology and so this could range from
weight loss eating therapy
allergic and diabetic management as well
as alternatives reality
dining and virtual food tourism and
potentially even for advertisements and
it could also be used as alternative
feed for astronauts which would allow
them to enjoy different foods whilst
traveling through space without the need
for any food preparation or cooking to
take place and so whilst it might still
be a while before we see this virtual
reality technology take place we may see
the use of augmented reality first and
so the key difference between virtual
and augmented reality is that virtual
reality involves a completely immersive
experience that shuts out physical world
whilst augmented reality tends to add
digital elements to a life here that you
can get from a camera to give an example
of augmented reality food take a look at
these two following videos in the first
video we can see that by wearing the
headsets
what was a black cup of coffee is now a
milky cup of coffee in the second
example we can see that the sushi on the
right has become more fatty so these two
examples can show you how the headsets
can manipulates the food that's present
is altered our perception of the foods
but does it also you have the same
impact of altering our perception of the
taste thinking that we are eating this
milky cup of coffee or more fatty sushi
well
okajima slab he develops this technology
put this to the test and tip 12
participants for males and eight females
aged between 20 and 24 who all ate
sashimi of tuna and evaluated their
taste whilst observing them disguised in
real-time through their headsets these
disguises altered the visual texture of
the tuna such that some pieces looks
more greasy and less lean than others
the participants then ate the tuna
unaware that whilst the disguises were
in place they were actually eating the
same pieces you know and evaluated the
deliciousness the grease enos and the
mouthfeel of the different pieces of
tuna the result
showed that participants answered that
the greasy texture is more greasy and
had better mouthful despite actually
eating the same tuna in other words
though although the participants were
eating the same tuna just by changing
the appearance to a greasy texture
produce a difference in the evaluation
of the foods so they had altered the
perception through altering the visual
texture of the tuna so not only does
this reports support that the appearance
of feeds is known to affect the taste
quality and flavor of the feeds and the
consumption of the feeds but it also has
potential for healthier food options
whereby if you are eating a healthier
piece of meats you can so use the
technology to think that you are
actually eating a more fatty version of
that same foods interestingly the same
labs also previously developed a
technology that they called meta cookie
which was an augmented reality system
for influencing the perceived flavor of
a cookie by overlaying visual and
olfactory cues onto a real cookie and
they merge this with another bit of
technology they called augmented satiety
which was an augmented reality system
that could also alter the perceive
society by changing the volume of the
foods so both these technologies could
in theory have great potential for
altering us food behaviors and
preventing cravings but are these
penalties going to be cheap and
obviously they're not ready available at
the moment so is there anything that you
can do now given this knowledge that we
can alter our perception of foods well
there have been a few studies that have
investigated this let me explain like
how in Pavlov's experiments image dog
salivates in anticipation of foods
thinking about the future consumption of
chocolates enhances our desire for it
and motivation to get it
however after eating and most the
chocolates our appetites usually wanes
and the offer of a second bar chocolate
is less appealing than the first but
what if we didn't actually eat the
chocolate we just imagined ourselves
eating the chocolates
would that have the same effect well
this was tested in the studies thoughts
for foods imagined consumption reduces
actual consumption so yes the title
somewhat gives away the results of this
paper but we'll go through it
nonetheless so the rationale behind the
initial design of the experiment was
built upon the concept of habituation
and so habituation is a decrease in a
response to a stimulus after repeated
exposure to that stimulus which is like
how a tenth bite of chocolates is less
decide than the first bites and so
habituation to feeds occurs too quickly
for it to result from just adjusted
feedback and so it's thought that it
instead occurs as a result of top-down
cognitive processes or pre ingested sent
three factors such as the texture of
smell interestingly perception and
mental imagery overlap with their neural
machinery and it's like how the thoughts
first by decoding across your leg can
produce the same increases in
perspiration and heart rates that would
result from a spiders actual presence
and so the authors of the study
rationalized that the overlap in
perception I mental representation could
suggest that thinking about the
consumption of the feeds should lead
people to habituate tulips so in one of
their experiments they had all
participants imagined performing 33
repetitive actions one at a time and
they had three different groups the
controls imagines inserting 30 3
quarters into a laundry machine
the second group imagined 30 quarters
into a laundry machine and then imagined
eating three M&Ms and then the last
group imagines inserting three quarters
into a laundry machine and then imagined
eating 30 M&Ms after this all of the
participants ate freely from a bowl
containing 40 grams for M&Ms for what
they thought was a taste test and then
afterwards they measured how much of the
food was eaten the results showed that
individuals who imagined eating 30 mm s8
significantly fewer M&Ms following the
experiments than those that only
imagined consuming three M&Ms so these
results show that three M&Ms were not
enough to sensitize and cause
habituation compared to imagining the
consumption of thirty M&Ms but all in
all the result seems to suggest that
mental representation alone can engender
habituation to a stimulus and suggests
that the difference between actual
experience and mental representations of
experience may be smaller than
previously assumed and so the results
from this study have been replicated by
other research groups however a more
recent study suggests that this
imagining consumption or feed may be
more complicated than we realize so this
study the effects of imaginary eating
and visual feed cube reactivity an
offense related potential study suggests
that there's no reliable increase or
decrease in consumption by imagining
eating and so this study wanted to look
into more detail at the underlying
neural mechanisms that were underpinning
this appetite reducing strategy of
imagining the consumption of foods so
their experimental setup was pretty
similar to the previous study they had
three different conditions in each
condition they listened to a guided
imagery script the oilers describes the
'i singles 30 colorful buttons shapes
chocolates
M&Ms the sorting of 30 M&Ms by column or
the sorting of 30 marbles by color and
so after the imagery tasks the
participants were presented with images
of M&Ms and marbles whilst their
electroencephalogram and craving ratings
were recorded and so the results of this
study showed that imaginary eating did
not reduce the appetite of value of M&M
pictures and the M&M sorting group
reported enhanced craving and shows
increased positivity towards the M&M
pictures compared to the other two
groups so this study
houses own limitations and that they
only did it with a small group of young
healthy women nonetheless it does show
or at least raises the warning that the
strategy may not work for everyone and
it also depends on how its performed for
example in this study they showed that
imagining handling the food was worse
than imagining consuming the foods and
as we saw from the previous study it was
about how much of that feed that was
imagined being eaten has an impact on
later consumption and other studies have
shown that these strategies may only
work for certain stimuli or certain
foods for example the strategy wasn't
successful for alcohol craving so
overall it looks like imagining the
consumption of foods could be a really
useful strategy for some or it could
leads in some adverse consequences and
increased cravings so proceeds with
caution or not at all so how will these
different technologies and mental
trickeries impacts our own futures well
some of the biggest challenges facing
human kinds are related to food
consumption and food systems this
includes health excess of meat
consumption using natural resources both
management and land use just to name a
few if we can actually harness some of
this mental trickery or eventually see
the adoption of these different virtual
reality and augmented reality
technologies at a pretty reasonable
price then yeah it would be very
interesting and potentially a successful
strategy to use so hopefully you've
learned something and as always thanks
for listening that's it
I'd like some fresh clear well-seasoned
perspective